hey what's up guys I'm Kay Bhd here and
I was actually out of town for spring
break during the galaxy s4 announcement
but I watched the whole thing so I've
had many hours to ponder exactly what
happened and why it happened so this is
the galaxy s4 features explain so if you
watch the unusually corny live reveal of
the device at Radio City Music Hall then
you saw what happen you saw it went down
but if you didn't it'll be the first
link below the like button on this video
absolutely worth skipping through and
checking out it's one of the corniest
but also funniest presentations of any
device I've ever seen usually they are
pretty corny especially things like a
soos and the companies just have a hard
time presenting the new products well
but this one is worth checking out so go
ahead and watch it it's pretty hilarious
now on paper the galaxy s4 is a small
speck bump in terms of hardware from the
galaxy s3 it has a slightly larger
5-inch display versus the 4.8 inch it
has a 1080p resolution versus the 720p
of the s3 it's also has a 2600 milliamp
hour battery versus the 2100 previously
it's also slightly lighter at 130 grams
versus 133 and it's also slightly
thinner at 7.9 millimeters thin and it
also has a 13 megapixel camera versus
the 8 so all these are numbers all these
are things that are physical Hardware
differences between the s4 and the s3 so
you can see where people are saying oh
it's just a minor upgrade a minor spec
difference and that's completely true
when you hold the s3 and the s4 next to
each other you can see the footage from
the hands-on at the event they look very
very similar and you'll be able to tell
that they are well basically parts of
the same family now the galaxy s3 when
it first came out was known to be a
powerhouse pretty much the highest end
smartphone you could get when it first
came out and still pretty high-end the
galaxy s4 being a speck bump from the s3
is also a very high-end phone the thing
is normal customers and normal average
people don't know that it's a high-end
phone the average person watching that
presentation doesn't know that it's an
octa-core processor overseas an
eight-core cpu the average person
doesn't know it has 2 gigabytes of RAM
and that's partially because Samsung
never actually said that they never even
said that it ran Android during the
presentation they saved all that for the
very end and a final slide after the
final credits that give the
full specs of the device so the fact
that it's a high-end hardware device
isn't really a big deal to Samsung why
is that that's because they're not
selling hardware anymore and it may
sound weird to say that but Samsung is
actually now selling or at least adding
value to their devices via software not
hardware they sold a lot of things based
on software and features not really
based on oh this has an 8 megapixel
camera I want to buy that no one is
buying the s3 for that reason people are
buying the s3 because it has Samsung
features and Samsung said well I think
we can expand on that with the Galaxy s4
so basically Samsung has seen that
adding value via software not hardware
is doing really well at getting and
attracting customers now the average
person may actually look at the
processor and say oh wow that's an 8
core processor that seems like it's a
great idea but for the most part they
don't flip out over those things they
don't flip out over the fact that it has
2 gigabytes of RAM or the fact that it
has Android 4.2 versus 4.1 they look at
the fact that you can turn the page
without touching the screen and they
freak out over things like that software
features that that you can look at other
phones and say well that phone can't do
that
I want the one that you can do magic
tricks with that seems like a really
cool phone to buy unload a link in the
description right below the like button
that has basically Samsung's wrap-up or
overview of all the new features that
they've added now you might have already
seen the galaxy s3 was very popular for
things like you know HDR mode in the
camera and group share and certain
things that are just named the way they
should because that soy some decided to
call them it also has a couple of things
in the s3 like s voice which we didn't
really like that much but it was a
unique Samsung feature the galaxy s4 and
as you'll see by the video in the
description goes way further and the
presentation that revealed the galaxy s4
spent way more time demoing these
features in a corny way but they demoed
the features for hours rather than going
over the specs because that is what
they're selling so I'll just go over a
few of these with you there if you think
that Samsung is trying to sell us in
that are just software based nothing
hardware based only things Samsung is
building into the software first of
which is called smart pause
we'll pause the video when you look away
from the display and resume playing it
when you look back the next one's called
air view which will actually let you
control the device without actually
touching it which is supposed to be good
for people who are you know doing your
nails or eating or something
you also have Samsung's watch on which
uses the IR blaster and the Galaxy s4 to
control a TV there's an optical reader
for scanning and business card info
there's group play which is allows you
to play music together on multiple
devices or a game and play the same game
on multiple devices there are new camera
filters that are similar to what you see
on the Galaxy camera there's also things
like sound and shot which will attach an
mp3 file to a photo or cinema photo
which will allow you to make a Jif of an
image you take a series of images and it
makes a gift for you there's also dual
shot which will allow you to use the
front-facing and back facing camera at
the same time you have chat on which
will allow you to do video chat using
both cameras or screen sharing using the
chat service there's also s translator
which does exactly what google
translator does live but it's just s
translator now you also have s voice
which we've seen already is the same
thing as Google now - the predictive
search but it's now Samsung based so you
have the S theme going on here and you
also have s health which is a monitor of
your physical health goals so if you
look at all these things that Samsung is
putting together it's pretty obvious
that there is a ton of s stuff and
Samsung stuff and they just named all of
the things they named everything they
possibly can to give it a name that
people will remember it's a feature that
they are trying to sell not a hardware
thing but a software thing and because
it is software pretty much all these
things are also going to be available in
an update of the galaxy s3 and the
galaxy note 2 now we tech people were of
course rolling our eyes when Samsung
spent half an hour showing how we could
swipe from tab to tab in the web browser
without touching the screen but that
wasn't for us that wasn't for the couple
hundred thousand tech people watching
that was for the people the average
people who actually have never seen that
happen before on any device and think
wow can the Sony Spurrier's e do that no
can the Oppo find five do that No
i phone do that no so I think I want
this coin instead usually we don't
really consider these features important
but then some of us tech people actually
think you know they actually ask the
question if I root this device and put
CyanogenMod on it am I going to lose
that s-pen feature am I going to lose
that airView feature so it's actually
becoming more important to us so the
Samsung S features and s stuff is
actually getting to us now and it's
becoming a thing that we associate with
the galaxy brand and the galaxy hardware
now all the software based enhancements
and things like that on top of android
without ever mentioning android
naturally brings up the question is
Samsung moving away from Google are they
moving away from Android altogether
could they build their phone on a new
operating system and my answer to that
would be no I don't think that's going
to happen anytime soon I think it could
go the way of the Kindle Fire where it
is built on top of Android technically
but you would never know unless they
told you and Samsung could probably pull
something like that off because they can
skin it so heavily and really make it
such a Samsung experience the way Amazon
made the Kindle Fire such an Amazon
experience that you would never know
it's running Android that being said
their tagline for the galaxy s4 is Life
Companion which is interesting by itself
I've never seen that as a tagline but
there you go
life companion has all these new
features that are all software based and
Samsung is clearly making a move towards
value added by a software instead of
value added by a hardware and that's the
galaxy s4's features explained there you
go guys hope you enjoyed this video if
you did definitely feel free to give it
a thumbs up and share it around
hopefully more people will be able to
understand exactly what Samsung is going
for here and if you enjoyed and if you
want to see more videos like this hit
that subscribe button below there are
more on the way either way thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys in
the next video
Faison
you